Okay, so we are doing so, as in the past, we've learned to introduce the self-purgant
day's name.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg, and this is the 20th of October 19th, 2011.
Okay, so today, I would like to start with you telling us about the role that you played
in the following papers, telling you what it is today.
Yeah, well, we talked about that last time, I guess.
Did we or did we not?
Well, I had a uncomfortable feeling I'm repeating myself here, but maybe not.
The effort to bring the papers here began when I sat at the head table with the Helen
Pauline during a meeting, short, in celebration of the awardee of the Pauline award, which
had been newly set up by three sections of the American Chemical Society, and she told
me at that time that people, several universities and other institutions were after Linus'
papers, but she said he didn't want them to go to these
institutions.
She said they didn't want all of his papers, and the University of Pennsylvania, I've seen
you remember, it was one of them, as well as Caltech and Stanford.
They only wanted slick proportions, but they wanted them all together, and so she said
to me that she had felt for a long time that the papers ought to come to Oregon State.
Now this was before Pauline's relations with Oregon State had been repaired, and she
went on to remark that she'd been talking to him, and she was trying to persuade him
that he should let bygones be bygones.
So that was Linus' late year?
Oh, gosh, that was the early 60s.
I'm sorry, my memory was hazy on these exact dates, but anyway, sometime now.
So I conveyed this information when I got back to the institution to President of the University
who at that time was Professor Johnson, and he called me and asked me if I thought that
Pauline would accept an invitation to come to the University and speak.
And I said, well, it could well be the case, it doesn't do any harm to try.
Now have I outlined the reasons before that Pauline did not want to come to the institution?
I don't know, I thought we talked about that.
It's odd because, well, never mind, in the late 40s, there was a faculty member at Oregon
State named Ralph Spitzer, who was denied tenure in the Department of Chemistry.
He was an excellent physical chemist, and he raised the issue that he was being fired
for his political beliefs, found that partly on the, on a letter that he had written,
that was published in Chemical and Engineering News, not supporting, but at least saying
that people ought to at least think about what this fellow, the sinko, and at that time
the Soviet Union was saying about the effect of environment on inheritance, and of course
this flew in the face of conventional wisdom of the time that everything was inherited.
So at any rate, the faculty at the chemistry department decided that they would not offer
him permanent tenure, which meant, of course, that he had to leave.
Now I knew all the members of the chemistry department having been an undergraduate here,
a consequence of this was that Ralph Spitzer asked the American Chemical Society for a hearing
on the issue of, I forgot what the ACS committee was, but anyway, the idea is that you're not
supposed to be discharged from a teaching position on grounds of your political beliefs.
And at the 1948 meeting of the American Chemical Society in San Francisco, which I attended,
Ralph made his case, and he was strongly supported by Linus Pauling.
The upside of all this was that I don't think the ACS committee wanted to get its hands
too deeply involved in this thing and not much ever came of it, but Pauling was rather
actively pursuing an ocean that Spitzer was a fine scientist and there could be no reason
that he shouldn't be kept on for professional reasons.
Well, AL Strand was president of Oregon State at that time and the news media or somebody
had made it brought up his knowledge of what Pauling had said and Strand got properly angry
and said, well, Oregon State can get along without Linus Pauling.
And Linus Pauling then said to the media, when this was reported to him, if they can get along
without Linus Pauling, they will.
So, from 1948 to all through the 50s, and of course, he won his Nobel Prize in 1954
and he spies later on, he had nothing to do with Oregon State.
But after Mrs. Pauling's comment to me and my relay of this information to Johnson, he
called me and said, as I said before, I would Pauling accept an invitation.
And Duke Orssis was tendered to him and he agreed, but he was going to come here
and he was not going to speak to the university as a whole, not going to speak
to the chemistry department on scientific subject.
So, there was a huge meeting held in the present, Gilt Orssian.
And there was a podium set up on one side of the floor and Stands were filled on the opposite side
as his kind of a stage.
And the head of time, Johnson, excuse me, asked me if I would introduce Pauling.
Well, as you think about that, here is a distinguished scientist coming to speak to the university
and the present university is not introducing him.
An ordinary faculty member like me was asked to do so.
But in my presence, Pauling and I, and Johnson and maybe some other people were there,
Johnson and Barney, that I was going to introduce him and he turned to me and said,
you're going to introduce me, Ken, and I said, yes, he's asked me to do that.
Pauling didn't say a word, but it was perfectly clear that he felt that it was appropriate
for the university president to do the introduction.
Well, so anyway, all of Mrs. Johnson and President Johnson and either Helen Pauling and Linus and Lisa
and I got in the limo and we were chauffeur over to the hall of Sam.
And everybody was sitting there waiting.
We filed in and went up on the stage and a few things were said.
And then I was supposed to give my introduction, which I did in a few minutes.
And about this time, Mrs. Pauling was about to speak and filed a group of students.
They were all black and many prominent among them were many members of the football team.
And this was at the time when the great punk and the decree that football players were not going to be able to wear beers.
And at that point, all hell broke loose and there were meetings on the campus regarding free speech
and the ability of the students to football team to have a personal appearance as they wished.
And the great punk and insisted that he finally resulted.
I think to saying that the beers didn't fit very well with the helmets and so on.
At any rate, in due course, these people, they said a few words and then they turned and abruptly filed out.
And very well behaved and so Pauling gave his speech, which was on peace and very well received and so on.
And then at the dinner of that evening, Helen Pauling said to me, she said,
oh, I was so surprised. She said, I thought all these flocks that had filed in were there were going to sing.
Well, that was the beginning of several overtures of Pauling.
He came back succeeding occasions but in the middle of all this.
Well, none in the middle, but I think at the beginning of all this, I had reported to Jensen that Pauling,
that Mrs. Pauling thought that Melinas' papers should come to Oregon State.
And of course, that would have been a great coup.
And so he gingerly broached the subject to Pauling.
I wrote him a letter about this, actually.
And Pauling in due course responded and saying that he would give it some thought that he was not yet prepared to give up his papers because he was still actively using the materials that were in.
And after Jensen retired, he was succeeded by the victor.
And I didn't think a great deal about this. Pauling was now coming and doing occasions.
And it suddenly occurred to me that I should forward the information that I had given to Jensen to him as well.
So I dug out the correspondence letter that I had written.
And President Jensen's response to it and typed another letter and sent it off to Dr. McPickery.
Jensen Ariel was repeated, and he again, queried Pauling on his papers.
This was now some several years later after the first overture, but he got the same response back.
Pauling wasn't yet ready to park through these papers.
And time went on, and John Byrne became president.
And once again, I hold out these papers. Now I've had two sets of correspondence and wrote to John, sent it off to him.
And his response was a little bit different. He immediately set up a committee on which I served.
And he made a concrete offer to Linus Pauling at the others' hand.
He said, we are very unparaphrasing him. Now you could talk to John and find out exactly how this went.
But the gist of it was that he said that they would create a, or they would not just set up a room or something.
They would create a special collections in which you could, you know, all of these papers could be housed.
They would build this for him, for him.
I think you see, I only see these facts from what I remember of our contacts.
But I should be checked with John.
The member of the committee was Rob Phillips, and some others who I can't remember now.
But anyway, this went on. And this time Pauling agreed. This is what would transpire.
But he wanted also the home papers to come as well.
He strongly felt all his life that after he had won the Peace Prize that she should have shared in it, because she was the one that actually stimulated his activity in that area.
Well, there was a huge, and he agreed to do this.
The first thing that he did was supply to the University, and you'll know all this in the records of the special collections.
You sent copies of the signatories to the proposal for the way of holding the petition for banning,
exploding explosion of nuclear weapons in the atmosphere, atmospheric test bands.
And that was the first thing I'd believed that came to Oregon State.
And only gradually did the other materials appear still because, of course,
when I was Pauling was acting until shortly before it was just a short time before it was done.
And I remember, excuse me, people here were not clear about how big this collection of Pauling was.
And so the Duke course, the University suggested that Pauling suggested that they come down and take a look at what he had.
And Krishnamurthy was sent down.
And he came back and told me I'd kind of crosses where his eyes should be.
He says there were over 90 filing cases down at Big Sur, where Pauling had his ranch.
You see, all the stuff had been moved down there.
And he said, Krishnamurthy was, of Lamesh, was just totally blown away by all of this.
Well, in Duke course, oh, after Pauling had agreed to give his papers,
there was a very, very elegant reception in Portland with several speakers and lavish dinner.
I was really a very, very nice affair and Pauling spoke.
And at that stage, somehow the question came up about all of his materials coming here.
And there had been some feelings.
Some of the family members, particularly Linda, I think, who felt that the family should have held control over some of these.
Pauling was asked, well, what does your family think about all of this?
And he says, well, Linda's here, why don't you ask her?
I don't remember what a response was, but I do remember Pauling's statement very clearly.
Well, as time went on, these things began to arrive.
So to arrive, these filing cases, now remember, well, I'm just describing to me a truck and pull up
and discourage a few of these filing cases and so on.
And that was a start, and that saw the project through to completion.
I don't know when the last of these materials actually arrived here at special collections,
but that's kind of the history of how they came here.
At least of the role that I played in it, doing nothing but reminding one president after another of what Pauling had,
what Mrs. Pauling had urged him to do in the fact that the relations had been repaired,
seemed between the university and Linus Pauling, seemed to suggest that things might go smoothly forward from there.
I do know that he was actually very fond of the university,
but he came on visits which he did not in frequently.
I usually was somehow involved in escorting him around,
walking the campus with him in a number of occasions.
We walked around the campus for one time.
We walked up in the old, who was in those days known as a chem-shack,
and didn't quite seriously remodel from Pauling's time,
but he seemed to be able to pick out the room in which he had been lecturing
when they either held on Pauling and appeared in his life.
And we walked down 15th Street and he showed me a house there that he had lived in as a student.
And I said to him, it's rather surprising,
because there's a certain parallelism in our experience here,
because I lived on 15th Street also, on the other side of the street,
just to have a block down, and I was an undergraduate student.
So I took a picture of him in Linda on the steps of the house.
I have it somewhere in my materials at home.
So the other thing I would say is that,
when Pauling began to come back to Oregon State on occasions,
we saw him and his wife as long as she was living quite frequently at home,
for dinner and places and things like that.
So we got to know them pretty well, better than when I was a student.
Of course, when I was a Kel Tech as a student, I was a student.
So it's been, for me, a wonderful, exhilarating experience.
So does that answer your query?
I've spent 20 minutes describing it.
Well, I'm interested in getting the memories of the times
that even on the minus can come up frequently in your house.
Oh, yeah, sure.
I have, I keep thinking that I have said some of this to you before,
but it may have been to somebody else.
But let me think just a moment.
One time, this was in the music anecdote,
and I don't know whether it involved well,
but I don't remember the whole clause for a dinner party
that the Paulings and we were invited to along with Dave Shoemaker,
who was chairman of our department,
who, by the way, knew Pauling very well.
He was a student at Kel Tech when I was.
And we all knew that Pauling,
he didn't shy away from alcohol.
He liked the vodka.
And on the evening of the dinner party,
just before about four o'clock,
I got a call from the host.
Sorry about my throat.
Asking me, I know that Dr. Pauling likes vodka,
says, I looked at my cupboard and I don't have any,
and I don't have any way of getting it.
Do you happen to have any vodka?
And I said, well, as a matter of fact, I do.
Am I told this story?
No.
Well, as a matter of fact, I do.
When I went into my cupboard,
I had maybe two thirds of a bottle there.
And so I got a brown paper bag,
and put the bottle in it.
And then we were picked up,
and the Paulings were picked up.
And we were driven up to the whole house,
running a doorbell, and he appeared.
And everybody shook hands,
and it is why I greeted everyone,
most pleasantly, and as I walked in,
I handed him my paper bag with a bottle in it.
And then every minute settled down for a bit,
and the living room before dinner was served.
The host said, well, would anybody like a drink?
And Dr. Pauling said, well,
you don't happen to have any vodka to you.
And the host said, well, as a matter of fact, I do.
So I thought that story, I think,
is very funny on retrospect,
but at any rate,
I never told Pauling this history at all.
So,
after either Helen died,
he continued to come to Oregon State,
often with Linda,
who accompanied him.
And they would come.
There were lots of things set up at the University of Receptions here.
There was a big library reception one time,
and there were seminars and chemistry,
and even in physics.
And then, usually, after these affairs,
and before dinner,
well, I say usually that,
often at any rate,
he and Linda would come to the house.
And on one occasion,
I'm referring still now
to his enjoyment of a drink before dinner.
We were on the campus walking around.
I said, what would you like to do now before the next reception,
which was an hour and a half?
I said, well, can we go to your house for a drink?
Yes, we could.
So, he went over to my house,
and he said, you don't have any vodka.
And he said, yeah, I thought, I know you like that.
And so, I got a glass,
a small tumbler,
like it puts a nice in it.
And he drank straight vodka.
It's essentially pure alcohol.
He told me at one other occasion.
Before dinner, he always had one of these cocktails,
but that was about it.
I started to pour, and I said, say, when?
He didn't say when.
When the thing was full, I stopped,
and he looked out and he looked at me with a smile.
There was a lot of ice in it,
so it really wasn't an awful lot of vodka, I think.
Anyway, we chatted a while,
and then he said to me, can I have another?
And Linda was sitting there,
and they had to go, this is the time we had to go to reception
over here in the library,
some place or another.
It was a library reception,
but it was held in the M.U.
and one of the rooms at the M.U.
And anyway, he says, can I have another vodka?
I put some more ice in it and pour it again.
And once again, I stopped when it was full,
and Linda was over there,
and said, daddy, daddy, you shouldn't do that.
You've got to go to a reception today.
Well, he just smiled at her,
and then we got up and walked out,
and he walked straight as a rod.
He didn't waiver at all.
We got in a car, went over there,
and he walked in,
and he shook hands with people.
You couldn't tell.
And, you know, he didn't weigh an awful lot.
He probably weighed 165 pounds, or 60 pounds,
or something.
A tall man and loose-jointed,
if everybody knows it.
And the reception went off just fine.
At one dinner party,
when this appalling was still alive,
we had tried to set it up in a nice fashion.
We had another pair of the Paulings,
and Lisa and me, and another couple of them,
and I'd been two more, maybe eight people.
But we had a first course with some white wine,
and I brought out the bottle,
and poured the white wine,
and the wine was picked up the bottle,
and it says, aw, he says, yeah,
this is my camp pronounces,
well, to eat, we say.
And he says, that's the same wine you served us last year.
Which, why he would remember,
of all of the dinner parties,
it'd been to what wine we had saved him
at the dinner party a year before,
it beats me.
But anyway, that was his remark.
It's been great fun knowing,
and so does that answer your question
about the papers and so on?
I want to ask you about the shoemakers.
We have their questions.
Yes.
That's a question.
You've ever seen in a vlog,
what do you call it on what they're like?
Is there people in there saying that?
Oh, well.
Dave's shoemaker and I were close friends,
and when they,
we served on a national committee together,
the United States,
the American Crystalographic Association,
has a committee on which, well,
at any rate, we had a meeting
to which I traveled in Washington, D.C.,
and Dave's shoemaker was the chairman of this committee.
Well, he and I had been students at Caltech,
and I knew him very well.
And at the end,
before I left,
we were looking for a replacement
for Bert Christensen, who was retiring.
And there was some talk,
given about bringing in, in fact,
it was preferred to bring in an outside person.
And I was impressed with how Dave,
who was then at MIT,
as professor of chemistry,
and a crystallographer,
ran this meeting,
he was very efficient.
I thought, gee, he'd be a good chairman.
And so, the meeting was,
one under a very, very tight schedule we had.
We worked furiously for several hours,
and then people had to disband,
and they were not having a dinner.
They were going to go home.
So I had almost, I said, Dave, I want to talk to you.
And he said, well, he says, you know,
I've got to catch a train.
I saw some such a time,
but he says, I'm on the way to the restroom.
Let's go to the restroom.
Well, this may sound indelicate,
and when you play it back again,
but there we were on a pair of urinals,
which were at an angle to each other.
So we were somewhere facing each other,
and I outlined this situation to him,
and asked him if he would consider,
think about being considered as department chairman.
Of course, Dave grew up in Idaho,
went to recall it, so he loved the West.
And although MIT was a very prestigious institution,
and they had a summer house,
he and Clara up in the mountains.
He said, yes, he would think about it.
So he came out,
and people liked him,
and he was off of the job.
Well, one of the conditions for the job
from his point of view was that his wife, Clara Brink,
was also a distinguished crystallographer,
and she wanted to be able to work
and to have an appointment.
At that time, there was a law.
In fact, it may still exist,
that came into being during the Depression.
It was an anti-nepotism law,
and it decreed that no members of the same family,
I don't remember how that was defined,
could work in the same department
or in fact in the same institution,
but even further in the state system of higher education,
except under unusual circumstances.
Well, about this time,
my wife was also a scientist.
We've been working together for years,
and we had a joint grant together,
and previous to that,
she had had appointments in the computer center
as an associate professor,
and so on.
So she was a professional,
but then it was determined,
that by a Bert Christensen,
that he wasn't going to allow her to work any longer
and be paid.
And so I went to him and said,
look, we've got this grant here,
and then you've signed it on the bottom,
the line item on the budget,
and Lisa has to be able to work.
She says, I'm not going to approve it.
So we took it over to Vern Shell,
a woman who was being a science at that time,
and brought it in, I showed him this,
and he says, well,
what didn't she tell me this sooner?
And I said, well, Bert Christensen,
and he were very close friends,
and I thought we should be talking to the chain of command here,
and he says, well,
here is a document that's legal.
He says she's going to be able to work on this grant
until it expires,
but after that,
if she wants to continue to be paid,
she'll have to be,
get a grant of her own.
Well, all this, a privilege,
a day of coming,
and one of his conditions,
as I say,
was his wife be allowed to work.
And Lisa's heart,
Mick Victor, came around,
and he looked at this,
and he says, okay.
He says, it says that you cannot have members
of the same family working in this institution
at the same time,
and being paid except under unusual circumstances.
He says, it's clear that a husband and wife's scientific
team is an unusual circumstance.
So he says, I am going to approve this.
And then Dave said, yeah,
but Ken Hedberg and his wife are exactly the same situation,
and Mick Victor says the same rule of applied on them.
Then Mick Victor said,
and this is very funny,
or Dave and I are close friends,
and our wives are friends.
And Mick Victor says,
the only thing I'm going to ask is that
you be responsible for Lisa, my wife,
and Ken would be responsible for Clara.
So once a term,
Dave would call me in these offices,
okay, Ken, how is Clara doing?
And we would have a big laugh,
but when I said, fine,
I said, how's Lucy doing fine?
He says, that's it.
So that's the history of,
with that condition,
Dave accepted the job,
and was here,
certain at capacity for several years,
until he retired,
and then he and Clara had an office in chemistry.
But he became ill with kidney disease.
Funny was on dialysis,
and died of a heart attack on time
during dialysis over an Albany.
Clara lived for several years after that,
and they set up a fund,
anchored with $100,000 to begin with
for the support of students in chemistry.
So that's Dave Shoemaker.
Dave and I shared an office at Caltech.
It's another interesting thing about him.
I have never been a smoker,
but he was.
And I told this story at meetings
when people will ask me about Dave.
I said, well, you know,
he didn't have an astray
because that wouldn't have lasted long.
He had a,
a French 75,
how it's so showcasing,
which is a brass thing,
with a rim on the bottom,
and still about two and a half feet high,
and I had a notch cut on the top
and he'd stick his cigarette in that,
flip it and the ashes would come down.
When he left,
that thing was folded a rim with ashes
in my office.
I threw it out, of course.
But he gave up smoking right after that
when he went to MIT.
And Clara never smoked,
and she had some respiratory problems
asthma and so on in her late years.
So that might have been part of the cause.
They have a distinguished son,
a Bobby Schumacher,
who went off to Britain,
and he's an historian.
And he's at one of the
Southwestern British universities,
and he, believe it or not,
has a position
as a professor of English history.
This is an American.
He's still an American citizen.
And he's written,
his thesis was a penetrating book,
a penetrating document,
which was published in book form,
and got very, very good reviews.
So I think that's an interesting sideline
to the Schumacher's.
Both scientists,
the son of historian,
lecturing on any English history to Brits,
and being academically rewarded for it.
We talked a little bit about your early trips
to Norway and your associations
with Norwegians,
and I wanted to talk a little bit more
about how that has continued
every time you mentioned Norway and Norwegians.
Oh, well.
Let's see.
I want to make sure that,
I'm talking about the things you would want me to.
How I went to Norway,
and how my relationship
with Norway and Norwegians
continued professionally through the years, is that?
We talked about the initial trip.
How about what?
We talked about your initial trip to Norway
and meeting you once, of course,
and then your early associations
with other baskets,
and then you know how to hassle
and you think that's true.
Yes, well.
And my professional associations
with Norway developed
as a consequence of knowing
Professor Oltowolstjonsen.
The later became richer of the university.
I don't remember whether I've mentioned that or not.
But when I was there,
I spent,
oh, I've lived in Norway probably
about five years or so old,
mostly on one year's stance.
And by the way,
Pauling has often come when I've been there,
and we've escorted him around
Bosjonsen and I,
the various places in Norway
and gone to meetings and talks
that he's held,
that he held.
At any rate,
at least his family connections
still, you know,
early years of our marriage
were pretty strong
and she liked to go back to Norway.
So, on my first sabbatical leave,
at Oregon State,
I decided I would go back to Norway.
We had some big projects going on
that we could share Norway
with our Norwegian colleagues.
So, I spent a year at the University of Oslo,
then again, in sabbatical,
and Lisa worked also as she came in.
And we had a nice house
arranged for us by the university.
Actually, it's an,
you know, an apartment.
They don't have houses there
by and large for younger people.
So,
during this time,
I met a number of people
that were essentially two laboratories
doing my kind of work.
One at the University of Oslo
and the other at the University of Trondheim,
which didn't have that name at the time.
And one of the,
Lisa got her training
in Boston's laboratory
in a number of other people
did.
Also, one of whom was a lady named
Maudet,
who went to Trondheim,
became professor there.
And I was invited up there
and gave a lecture,
and she introduced me to a student of hers
named Koldjörn Hagen.
And Koldjörn Hagen,
the question was,
he was just finishing his degree
and I was looking for a postdoctoral associate.
So, I said to Maudet,
I said,
well, is he pretty good?
And she said, yes, he's very good.
So, Koldjörn came to the United States.
That was the beginning
of a professional relationship.
I think that,
probably my strongest professional relationship,
apart from that,
of course,
is my wife and the work
that she does in the laboratory
of anyone.
And he has spent a total of six years
in Koldjörn Hagen,
coming at various times
for years,
and once, twice,
two-year leave,
and so on.
And...
Sorry, man.
How did he spell his name?
Just to make sure he...
Hagen,
H-H-A-G-E-M,
and the first name is Koldjörn.
Koldjörn is,
it's K-O-L,
and then B-J,
Umblaut-O-R-M.
That means bear in the origin.
So, anyway,
this relationship
went on through the years,
and then one time,
I received an invitation,
oh, I was asked several times
to serve on doctoral committees.
And one of them was
Maudet's committee,
when she obtained her doctorate,
that was quite early in my career,
and that was lots of fun,
because it was all done very formally, you know,
there's a first opponent,
a second opponent,
and then a third one
was kind of a humorous opponent.
So, I was the first opponent.
And in these formal things,
you're dressed very formally
on the old days,
you used to wear tuxedos.
The candidate was a man,
a tuxedo.
But we had a podium,
and the candidate was over here,
Maudet,
and I was here,
and there was an auditorium for people,
and I had been given her thesis,
and I would ask her questions,
and she would answer,
and so on.
And at the end,
by the way,
I was paid a substantial amount of money for this,
and that was a norm for the time.
So, we had a tremendous,
the tradition is that
a successful candidate throws a party,
and we had a wonderful,
absolutely wonderful dinner party
at her house,
that's not formed in association,
that continued until her death years later,
but she's spent time in Cornalos also.
At any rate,
so after in my mid-career,
when Collegor and Gropian informed me
that the university had elected
to give me an honorary degree,
so I could come up there,
and that was a tremendous fun also.
There were three of us
who were awarded an honorary degree,
and one of the guys was a fellow
from Germany,
who had just won the Nobel Prize,
so I felt myself in distinguished companies.
And there was a big party,
I still think of that great funness.
And then, I think sometime before this,
I was elected to membership
in the Origin Academy of Sciences,
and a bit later,
on another occasion,
a few years later,
these are the American Equivalents.
The actual Norwegian name is,
well, I don't have to describe it,
but anyway,
let's say one of them is an origin counter-part
of the National Academy of Sciences here,
and the other one is an origin counter-part
of the American Academy of Arts and Sciences,
and I've been asked,
I've been awarded a membership in each one of these.
So all of this is a consequence
of this long stretch of professional affiliation
I've had with people in Norway.
I think the laboratory
that does my kind of work in Oslo is now extinct,
and the one in the Trondheim is also,
everybody who is involved in my day,
just as I am, is retired.
And so, the University
efforts have gone off in different directions,
but everyone that belongs to this laboratory,
almost every single person in Oslo,
I think barring one,
has been sometime in my laboratory,
and almost everyone in Trondheim
spent time in my laboratory.
So there's a,
and that number is,
oh, maybe
10 or 15 people all together
who spent as long as two years
in my laboratory.
I have a book in my office,
in which I formed the early habit
of taking a photo and picture
and pasting the book
and asking them to sign the name to it,
and all of these people are there.
And on one occasion,
when I was going to go to Norway,
I was asked if I would give a talk in Trondheim.
And I said, yes,
and I got to thinking about this.
So, cold and hot,
and by this time,
I'd become a professor in Trondheim.
So I fished out all the pictures
that I had
and arranged them in sequence
from the time he first came,
the time he last came,
and there were about eight of them.
And I had a series of slides
made of these.
When I came to talk,
I said, I want to show you the history of one
of our good friends.
And so,
I put these up there
and to the immense hilarity
of the audience
because they'd never seen Hogan
as a young man.
They'd only seen it
and I could show his development
with dates underneath it.
Well, that made quite a hit
in that talk.
He's never let me forget about that,
even.
So, it's been a great
boon and fun for me.
So, I have also formed
professional attachments
and friends with people
at the University of Trondheim,
which is in the Northern Norway,
and at the University of Oregon,
in the West Coast.
So, it's been a very fine thing
for me.
I have a list of names
of people from the
OSU Chemistry Department
over the years.
I'm going to share any
recollections that you have
about some of these folks.
John Fulton.
John Fulton was the only
one that I never met
in person.
When I came to Oregon State
in 1939, Gilbert
was chair.
And I don't know how long
he had been chairman at that point.
But he certainly was still
chairman in 1956,
when I returned.
And I think he actually
retired from the
chairmanship in 1957,
wanting to spend the last
two years of his life
doing teaching and research
again.
That's when Christensen succeeded
in.
So, every, I don't know
the Christmas, whether you've
seen all the pictures
in chemistry, have you?
If you go into the main
hall, Gilbert Hall,
on the end, nearest
here, the library,
and walk down on the left-hand
side, high up is a chronological
arrangement of all professors
that have been present at this
in that department and retired.
John Fulton was the first
one in the list.
Every single person I have known
of a succeeding 20 or 30
that belonged down the hall.
Of course, the last,
I've been retired long enough,
so I'm quite a long ways
from the end now.
But everybody on to the
present I've known them all,
except Fulton.
That's what kind of we
got that.
How about thanks for
going through it?
Sorry.
Thanks for going through it.
Go through it?
Go through it.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
He didn't have an active
role in the chemistry department.
He was Dean of the College of
Science, and during the war,
for a short time, he was
acting president of the
University, if I remember this
correctly.
But he was a very
erudite man,
and a wonderful personality.
I didn't know him well.
I met him on a number of
occasions, and he was still
alive when I returned to
the University.
But he suffered from,
I don't remember whether it was
Parkinson's or all.
I think it was all
some of the species that he
finally succumbed to.
But he was just a wonderful
guy.
His family has set up a
researcher ward in his name,
called a girlfriend,
and that's given every
year to a faculty member.
Errol Gilbert.
The hall was not named
Gilbert Hall until after he
died, because there was at
that time a rule against
naming buildings after
living people.
Gilbert was a big guy.
He walked with a kind of
shuffle.
He was a physical chemist.
He had two sons, Henry
and Allen.
Henry was a classmate of
mine as an undergraduate,
and in the war broke out he
was involved in war work or
over in Albany at the,
I don't know, there was a
bureau of mines in there,
whether he was working with
watching or whatever on
war work.
But he died of a,
of a malignancy.
People think it was related
to ingestion or inhalation
of burilia, which was
extremely toxic.
His son, Allen Gilbert,
I mean his brother,
Allen Gilbert, Errol Gilbert
was a surgeon at the
Kolaula's clinic for many
years.
He retired as I understand
it because he developed
severe arthritis in his hands.
He was a very nice guy.
Well, Gilbert, I had only one
course from him when I was an
undergraduate.
The department chairman
actually taught them.
And he taught physical
chemistry.
I recall one kind of
plungent experience with
Errol Gilbert when I was an
undergraduate.
There was a chemistry
honor society called
Philanboopsalon.
And I was elected
membership in this.
And Henry Gilbert, who was a
chemistry major, was not.
Now, Henry Gilbert was a,
I want to say, a very
outspoken, outgoing guy.
And he was not elected
to, when you're elected to
membership of voters taken.
And if there is any, I don't
recall what the circumstances of
the election, what the rules
are, or were at that time.
But he was not elected.
And Errol Gilbert, his father
was very upset at this.
And he called me into his
office.
And he says, I cannot ask you
who he, in a very
different way, let me know he was
very disappointed that Henry had
not been elected.
At that time, the chemistry,
the Philanboopsalon had members
comprising majors in chemistry
and chemical engineers largely.
And he says, I can't ask you,
of course, about the vote.
But he said, can you tell me this?
I suspect, was it mostly the
engineers that were involved in
this negative vote.
And I hesitated a long time
and I said, well, you know, I
felt I had to answer it.
And I said, yes, it was.
And he just shrugged his shoulders.
I know he deplored it.
There was a strong Greek
community on the campus at the
time that I was here.
And there was a kind of a social
division between the independence
and the Greeks.
And that division seemed to
extend into honor societies as
well.
People were voted for membership.
And you know, in retrospect,
it's utterly ridiculous to think
that somebody who is academically
well qualified would be
not voted into an organization for
personality reasons.
I like Henry Gilbert.
We got along just fine.
And he didn't have the shy,
respectful attitude that maybe
these people expected he should have.
But that was very upsetting to
Earl Gilbert.
Another thing about the
Gilberts, once a year,
they invited the chemistry department
to dinner at their house.
But there's the faculty and
there's spouses.
And there was always a very nice
dinner.
Now, the Gilberts were tea
totalers.
No alcohol was served.
Tomatoes were served instead.
And that was all well and good.
Everybody understood this.
Then the Gilberts went off.
I think that may have been one
summer.
They took a trip to France.
And they came back.
And Wendell's label,
a good friend of mine,
was hosting a dinner party.
And he asked, Elise and I were
invited as were the Gilberts and
some other people in physical chemistry.
And it was a very nice dinner.
And Wendell asked me ahead of time.
He says, do you think I should
offer people a
cherry or a drink or a wine
with dinner?
And I said, well,
it's your party.
Why not?
And the Gilberts, as I say,
just come back from this trip in France.
So Wendell and Duke,
of course, asked everybody what they
did for her and Earl Gilbert said,
well, I'll have a glass of
tomato juice.
And his wife,
said, I think I'd like some
cherry.
I thought, Gilbert wins.
And she had a glass of
cherry on the conversation and
she said, my that was nice,
cherry.
I liked that very much.
And Gilbert modeled,
and I liked my tomato juice too.
I understood that I don't
know where I got this information,
but I understood that as they
traveled through France,
they did drink wine,
because that's about the only
thing that you would be
served at a meal.
And maybe that's how Mrs.
Gilbert, just for the moment,
I can't remember her name,
but it'll come to me.
They were nice people.
I liked them.
Well, the next person on my
list is Linda Slavo.
Oh.
Linda was a remarkable person.
I held him in the highest regard,
not when I first came,
but later on.
When I first came,
did I mention that there was
Christensen became chairman after
Gilbert, but that was not
without a hitch in the
proceedings.
Have I ever mentioned that?
Well, for some gone for
sake and reason,
it was determined that the
department should not only
elect, which was reasonable
enough that should vote for who
they would propose the department
chairman.
Of course, that was non-binding
because the dean is the one
who makes a decision.
But one of the things for some
reason, nobody seems to remember
this, but me, I'll have to dig
out my records.
The department decided it was
going to have a constitution.
Democracy was going to rule.
Now, if you think about that,
how ridiculous can you imagine
you can't run a department
as a democracy with a
legislation that determines things.
You've got to have a department
chairman that makes things happen.
You know, that was at me.
Slayball ran for he came
around, and I was new at this
time, a longer Tom Parsons,
and I knew that he was a
candidate. He came around,
and very subtle way was
discussing this.
And Christensen was the
heir apparent.
As I explained, Berncello
then was the dean, and they
were good friends.
And everybody expected that
Christensen, as the oldest
and most experienced and
longest serving department
member, would become chairman.
He was a good scientist.
He did hard work, and he's one
of the few people who were
regularly publishing at Oregon
state at that time.
Well, Slayball was running
also, and it was determined that
the person who won the elections
name would go forward.
Now, I don't remember whether
Slayball won this election.
I don't know how many votes were
cast, maybe 20, all told, or
30, won the election by one vote.
And all hell broke loose.
You know, Christensen was
terribly upset.
And as Slayball told me
later, he was invited over
to a dean's office.
I don't know whether it was
Shullam and there's someone else.
And sat down and talked to
in a friendly manner by this
official to point it out that
he was a young man and that
the department would undoubtedly
run better if somebody
with long experience was
chairman.
And as a young man, he would have
plenty of chances to rise through
the hierarchy into administrative
position.
And Slayball, reading the handwriting
on the wall, just then announced
that he was withdrawing his name
from consideration.
That was his public statement,
but his private feelings I
have relayed to you.
So, Christensen became chairman.
And I think he always had that
what do I want to call it,
feeling of having been rejected
hanging over him for a long time
so he stole very hard to be
what he thought would be a good
chairman.
And I could tell you about that
also.
But Slayball was a distinguished
teacher.
His lectures were very popular.
And he had a most original mind.
He did unusual things.
He built himself a,
it was rare at that time.
A three-wheeled bicycle
with enclosed and
a canopy over the top,
which had plastic windows
in front, so he was shielded
from the wind.
And he would pedal this thing
to work and add a little flag
up the back,
just as if you see some
of the handicapped people
using these today.
Not him.
He had this.
Later on, he built something
similar.
And he put a motor on it.
It was an electric motor
and operated by a battery.
He billed all himself.
He lived on,
on Grant's street,
up about
thirty-fourth street
on the right-hand side.
And he had hedges there.
And he trimmed these hedges.
So what is the
art form known when you cut
these in the form of shapes
and animals?
He meticulously groomed
these plants and he had one
sitting there that had wheels
on it and a canopy
and a steering wheel.
Just one bush that had been
sculpted into that shape.
Others he sculpted
into animal shapes.
And then in his driveway
which slipped down to the street,
he painted one
of the very famous
what's the guy's name
who does these peculiar
drawings
they're famous now.
He's a famous artist.
The water that runs up
pill without seeming to do
some.
Yes, sir.
He painted the black
and white doves
that meshed together
and are going down to the sidewalk.
He billed outside a bench
into the wall.
His yard sloped down
to a concrete area there.
And he billed a bench
in there, a wood.
And it says,
I don't remember the Italian
words exactly
or the pronunciation,
but it's in a sense
that something
came out of their public
or for the convenience
of the public.
We got to know him
and his wife
very well.
Later on,
we saw them socially
a good deal.
And Louis,
his wife, was a very
nice lady.
Wendell,
he had this nice house.
He had an idea.
He went down to the GT
one time.
And he bought
or brought.
I think he was
they were given
to him a number
of plates
which were used
in printing,
which were all black
on the top.
Perhaps a glass
or something.
I don't know.
But he bought a whole bunch
of these
and he billed himself a box
on his roof.
And he bought
of these things
so the sun would hit it.
And he slowly circulated
air through this,
which he then arranged
to be pumped down
into his house.
And he still had
to have a furnace,
of course.
But he said,
this noticeably
reduced his heating costs.
Then in later years,
he would quit early
and he said,
I need some exercise
and we'd go home.
And I discovered
he was digging a huge
sister in his yard.
And I saw this thing
being constructed
and he had great lines
and back too.
It wasn't a big yard,
but he had great lines as well.
And when this was completed,
you know,
we were up there a dinner
one time.
She says, come and see my sister
and it was just completed.
And I looked down
and this down thing.
It was about eight feet
across and it was
at least eight feet tall.
It was a huge thing
and he dug it all
by hand,
made the lining
and everything in it.
Concrete it
all up
and so on.
And he said, there it is.
He says, he's going
to start filling it.
He says, let's go down
and he had a ladder
built on the side.
So we went down.
We sat down
and a couple chairs
in the bottom,
while he described this sister
into me.
So then we went upstairs
and he covered it
and he piped all the water
that fell on his roof.
All of that went
into the sister
and which he then
pumped out to water
his garden.
The front lawn
and the vines
and back, everything.
And then the city then
had an assessment
for storm for drainage.
So he went down to the city
and said he wanted to have
his drainage reduced
because the property
was not as big
as they said it was
and he gave him an estimate
of the square footage
of the roof on his house
and he wanted
his proportional reduction
in his drainage sheet.
The city would have no
nothing to do with this.
At which point he realized
that this drainage
was really a tax
on the amount of land
that you had,
not really on.
It disguised the way he
put it to me.
So that was Wendell.
He died of a heart attack
in his sleep.
And it was a tragic thing.
Lois was very upset
and she continued
to live in the house
for quite a while.
And she would come
to our house regularly
and we would go
up there to dinner
and she came to us
for dinner.
And I did some work
a little work
in our house
for her.
I repaired the toilet
that was leaking
around the seam at the bottom.
I put a new boot in it
and I drilled a hole in the door
and put one of these viewports
in it for a few things
like that.
And she developed an infection
that by the time it was diagnosed,
her condition was so poor
that she even had to treatment
that she couldn't recover
and she eventually died
from it.
Not the infection,
but the fact that she had no
reserves left.
So I was,
that's the story
of the labels that I know.
They had one son
who is in California still.
He has no children
and he is an orthopedic surgeon.
He had a daughter named Jane
who babysits our kids
when they were small.
And she became for reasons
that were never entirely
clear to me as strange
from her mother.
And she lives in Seattle.
She was married
and then divorced.
And I think I've seen her once
up there, but I don't know
what's become of her since then.
That's about what I know
of the labels.
Oh yes.
Well,
Bert very much wanted people
to realize that
convinced people he was
a very good department chairman
and we have in the chemistry department
at that time we have a
source of chemicals.
Let's call it a storeroom.
There's a lot of chemicals used
and that time an organic chemistry
and so on was a big supply
and he would buy these
milk and they would be
repackaged in jars
and labeled with a number
and so on on them.
And other departments
that couldn't afford a
storeroom like this,
this would be sold to them.
At the price
that was listed or maybe
just a trifle less of the price
listed for the same
size container
of the same material
and chemicals catalog.
And by buying it both
and repackaging it,
we saved money.
He made money.
And that money was used
to support various things
to realize on those days
there was almost no money
for anything.
If you wanted to replace
the equipment,
you know, it was like pulling
teats to get any money
from the university for that.
He would proceed
in the department
and to keep us just
at least hanging on.
The trouble with this was
that this money which
went into a car
had to be spent
by the 30th of June.
And sometimes
Christmas was very frugal.
He would get all this stuff
piled up there and then
he didn't have a way
of spending it before the end.
So all sorts of peculiar
things happened.
He came down to me one time
and says, can how do you like
to have your office painted?
I said, my office painted.
I don't need my office painted.
And he said, well, you know,
it looks a little dingy in here.
We should paint a few of these offices
and just shrugged
and so my office was painted.
And that used up some of the money.
He says, you know, I don't like to look
at all these pipes overhead.
In the basement, everything was open.
All sorts of vents and pipes
that looked terrible.
He says, I think, well, how would you
react to the idea
that we put a false ceiling
in a masculine stuff?
I said, well, can do it if you want.
I don't see the need for it.
In fact, it improves
the appearance of things,
but it also makes it
more difficult to locate the source of problems.
So a new course,
we have that false ceiling,
which if you go into the basement of Gilbert,
you can see it's still there.
It's got holes punched in it.
It's white panels suspended
from the ceiling.
So,
Burke was very,
very conscious of
how I want to say.
He was recovering his tracks all the time.
And one of the reasons
that he refused to renew,
my wife's appointment,
had nothing at all to do with science,
anything like that.
She was paid very modestly
on any event.
But, for the first time in history,
just before he took this action,
the city of Corvallis
defeated a bond measure
designed to support schools.
And he thought,
boy,
people are looking at what
the education system is doing
and here they're going to see
if there's a faculty member's wife
who's being paid on a faculty member,
being paid through the system.
Of course, my grants were
to the university and they were paid.
And he decided he couldn't tolerate
the possibility
of somebody objecting to this.
And that was the reason
that he advanced
to me. He says,
we have to be very careful
of our image.
He advanced to Lisa.
I didn't have anything to do with it.
She wrote him a letter,
went to see him, wrote him another letter,
and nothing happened.
Finally, he refused to answer her letters
and that's when we went
over to the dean.
But I remember a remark,
he was a gruffle guy
and he spoke
down like this. He says,
he says, bird is sort of
like a country horse.
He shies it a paper
in the road.
So that's bird.
He contributed
after he retired.
He sent up a fund
designed to help graduate students
meetings
when they were working in research
with research groups for which
there was no money.
And that was used quite a lot
and I
thanked him a couple of times
when I saw him on the streets
and he says, oh, well,
please, he says, if he need
more money, let me know.
And I don't know whether he put
more money up or not.
I was not the department gentleman.
So that's a brilliant gentleman.
I don't
remember much about
WERN
on the same
personal or intimate basis
that I mentioned to these other people
because he was sitting in the dean's office
at the time.
Well, when I first came here,
he was said of something
like the research institute.
And it turned out
in the early days
there was a group of biochemists
associated with chemistry
among who
was
Sheldon.
And he decided
that he would like to
set up this independent entity.
There are lots of reasons for it
because overhead that was returned
to these
agencies.
At that time, the university returned
part of the overhead to the departments.
And the departments then could
determine how they were going to use this
returned overhead.
Well, I think WERN had some
conditions.
Clearly, he did.
He was a nice guy, by the way.
He arranged,
I'm sure, with the support of
Chris and Sun,
to take these biochemists
and to set up what they call
the Science Research Institute,
which was largely biochemistry.
And then later on,
that became,
I think,
kind of morphed
into,
along with perhaps
other departments.
I'm not quite sure
about chemistry and bio physics.
And then WERN became
department chef,
and became D.
Pardon me.
He suffered from health problems,
serious ones.
He had very high blood pressure
at one stage,
and he died really rather young.
His life was
very well known,
also,
because I range, her name was
I range,
but I think she served
she was certainly involved
in local politics.
And I don't know whether
she'll in the middle school
is, they were philanthropic,
also.
Whether that followed
mostly from her work,
or from them jointly as
they were.
So that's about as much as I
know, WERN.
I'd see him on the street
when she had cans
and chat a bit,
and then I had this,
at least, and I had this
contact with him in occasion
of her appointment.
And that's about all I had to do
with him.
Well, Carol is
a wonderful guy.
And I think he's
very proud of him as one of the,
certainly one of the better
chairman's that I have
experienced here.
Carol had a research program
in inorganic chemistry
when I first came.
And he decided he would
whatever reason.
I think his research was
slowing down that he would
run for department chairman.
And I think that there were
two choices.
One of them was
Dara Thomas.
And the other was
Carol.
And I think the ultimate decision
was made by the dean
that it would be Dara Thomas.
And after he served for
a term, Carol became
department chairman.
Now,
Carol,
he really ran the department
the way that a lot of us
would like to see it done.
He once professed to me,
he says, look, he says, my research
days are over. I view
my role in this department
as to expedite the research
and teaching potential
of the department to the
maximum possible.
And so he was
the difference between him
and Christensen's
and say to choose an example.
Christensen, you couldn't
pry a dime out of it.
Until the end,
when you saw this
flamboyant expenditures being
made, I'd go to Carol
and I'd say, look, I need some
money from my returned overhead
by the way.
In those days, the department
received returned overhead
but the department
to determine what they did
with the overhead. And our department had a practice
of returning about
80% of the overhead
that was derived from
the research grant of an individual
to that individual.
So if you had a big research
grant of which a
lot of overhead was
extracted, returned to the department,
then you would have a chunk of money
to deal with because I think
they returned 80% or so
and you could use that any way you
want. Now,
what happened was that
a notice would be sent about
that returned overhead was now
available and you should
write down what your needs are.
Now, it wasn't that
the overhead was
directed specifically to the
individual who had earned it.
But that would
receive some priority.
But a lot of us didn't need
all of our overhead and so we
build up formally speaking
an account.
Other people who needed
equipment that exceeded the
returned overhead could use the
returned overhead and then
you would have a credit so to speak.
Well, of course, it's not a
business and
looking back, a
perspicacious individual would have
seen that this can't
persist and the guys who
have the credits are probably
never going to realize there
are money back again.
Whereas those guys who are in
debt, you know, the department is
going to decide they're not going to
distribute overhead anymore.
And so they come out and
swim like a rose.
Well, I didn't need all of my money
because I had equipment budgets
and I could buy an
account.
Well, I went to him on a couple
of occasions saying, I need
this or I need that carol and I
don't have the money and my budget
for it. He says, how much is
it? I'd tell him.
He'd look at this and he'd say,
okay, go ahead, buy it.
And he was very effective in
this way and I think people
respected him for that because
people didn't go to him to try
things they really didn't need.
And this isn't keeping with his
professed remark to me.
It's remarked to me that he
was going to do what he could to
expedite the teaching and
research activities of the
department. If you needed money for
your research and you didn't have it,
he tried to get it for you.
He was very good.
You know, he's still around.
We have an old man's lunch
once a month.
Did you know that?
The old man's lunch started
way, way back
in 1986.
And it started
with bus marvel,
Elliott Marvel, a professor of
organic chemistry who retired
and
he was very ambitious.
And it may have been Harry
Frand also decided they would
meet for lunch.
And then there were probably
four of them all told.
And then when I retired,
they decided that I would be
invited to this and then
it became a kind of a monthly
affair.
And as people have retired,
that has kept going.
So every retiree in
chemistry,
and two or three in biochemistry
in bio physics,
Chris Matthews comes,
Ken Van Holt is a part of it.
Bob Becker comes,
then several chemists come.
Several chemists who could
come don't because their active
tennis player is still,
and they have matches Wednesday
at noon when we have our meetings
once a month.
And he's a very
lively guy.
He's been very active.
He bought a house
on the area road.
He's been an active
kayaker for years.
And finally, he decided
that the commute
for him and his wife was
just too much.
So they sold that property
to him.
At least in the process of selling it
and bought some last year here
in town where he's now living.
But he's still kayaks.
In fact, they went down the
road recently.
And he's been on the Grand Canyon
more than once in his own
kayak.
So he's very active,
physically.
Wonderful guy.
What are some of the
more critical or memorable
things that you think
about in 10 years?
What were the status
teams?
A memorable experience is
working with graduate students.
Well,
I'm thinking here as
I'm sitting.
I've had
some very good graduate students
and some that were
not so good.
Almost all of whom
have finished and gotten
a degree.
Let me name one
who came along fairly late.
His name was
Chin-Fan Huang.
And he was a Chinese
national.
And he came here
when, oh,
I'd have to look to see,
he's been almost 20 years
now.
Well, perhaps even more
than that.
From China,
when it was still a highly
restricted place.
And he grew up in time
of the cultural revolution.
And by his own
bootstrapped,
lifted himself up.
And he
became aware of a position
I had.
And I don't remember
the details, but I decided he
would be a good addition.
And I think he was coming
at the beginning with his own
money.
So he arrived.
And I had several students
working with me
at that time.
And one of these
was a
young woman that
was working away when he showed
up. And I happened to be
away the day he arrived.
He came into the laboratory.
This young woman was trying to
do some work on her
computer.
And he spoke
rather poor English
language.
But he was
as gong-hole as
they could come.
And after a while,
I think a day or two later
this girl came to me
and said, I can't stand this
guy. She says, over my shoulder
all the time. That's me.
Also, it's a question.
He was so eager.
Well,
by this time I was taking him
to enrollment courses.
And he was a very
anxious to start research.
And he was dynamic.
He was a tremendous
researcher.
And he was an older man.
And he had had a lot of work
in chemistry,
even at the theoretical
that was very knowledgeable.
But he was required
to fulfill our department
requirements, of course, for course
work. And he enrolled
in theoretical chemistry.
And he got
straight-age, no question about it.
At the end of his
first year, he was
hold of the outstanding
incoming graduate student.
And then a year later he was
hold of the outstanding
graduate student. And each of
these carried financial
stipends, not a great deal, but some.
And one day he came to me
and said, you know,
the Chinese are very
cognizant of,
let's say,
the social hierarchy
and the
deference which should be
paid to people who occupy a
status a little
more elevated than yours.
And so he came to me
having just attended lecture
and quantum mechanics
by one of our faculty members.
And he said to me,
very quietly, he said,
is it all right
to correct a professor when he's
wrong?
And I said,
yes it is.
You should tell him
or raise the issue
and tell him about it and say
that you think this is
the right answer.
But I'm not quite sure
he ever followed through on that.
Well, he did a
lot of work. And then
at the end of his
graduation he got his degree.
He worked for a while with
Doug Kessler in chemistry.
And then
a colleague of mine that
Michigan named Larry Bartel
was looking for somebody and I
recommended him
and of course he shows up
and Larry isn't doing quite the same
kind of work that I am.
And Larry has a very
abrasive, uh,
no nonsense personality.
But I think he met his
match in Geneva and
Juan.
Because he would tell Juan to
do something and Juan would do it.
But then he would point out he could
do it better this way.
And he would do it that way.
So it turns out that
now Juan was married
and he could hardly wait
to come to this country.
And finally he arranged
so that she could come.
And they had two children,
two boys,
which is, of course,
out of the line there.
At any rate, the first thing
that the woman came, he wanted
her here so she could cook
and he could spend more time
doing research.
And he enrolled his son
I guess both kids,
but I don't remember
so much about the younger.
Anyway, he was very distressed
because after a while the
younger son was not
washing home after school
and spending the rest of the
afternoon studying, the son
became quite used to American
manners. And he liked the
social life and so on.
And this distressed his father
immensely, who expected
a problem. And I said,
Jim Phan, I said,
how's your son doing?
Well, he could do better.
He could come home and he could
be studying advanced things.
And I said, well, how are his
grades? He said, what grades?
I said, well, what are the
marks? He gets the courses.
He says, well, he gets all
A's. So it wasn't an
upper Jim Phan that his kid was
excelling by American standards.
He went on. His wife had to
go home or be sex barred.
And then he learned
after she'd been home a long
time that she was pregnant.
At which time he immediately
divorced her.
That's unknown all there you
see. And I think I don't
know whether his sons had gone
back or whether they stayed with
him here or not. I just don't
know that. But then you
began to look for a new wife.
And this is kind of a male
order of proposition. And so I
don't know how the Chinese do
it traditionally. But at any
rate, he found some woman
in Shanghai and he went to
visit her. And I think they
eventually married.
And she's a little more modern
life than he was. And she
joined even Minnesota. And I
think they're still there.
I don't know whether they
have any children together or
not. But he found a job in
an industry and an
arbor. But he still works
weekends in Larry Bartel's
laboratory. So he's the most
notable graduate student from
several points of view that I've
had postdocs that are even
just as remarkable, one from
Japan in particular. We're
getting on here. How long do you
want to go? I can go a
lot longer if you'd like.
Well, let me talk about one of
my postdocs. I mean, I have a
host of graduate students and each
one of those has got his own
personalities. And some have been
very productive, some less
productive. But I want to
mention something that I think
is a remarkable
life or parallel lives.
There was a distinguished
professor named Yoneso Morino
in Japan at the
University of Tokyo. And in
1960, I think it was
1962. But at any
rate, I had a
role letter. I was looking
for a postdoc role
appointee. Yone
as he was called Morino. We
became friends and I've seen
him all over the world at
meetings in Norway and other
places. He wrote to me about
his student named Machio
Iwasaki, who would like to
study. And he could
recommend him. Well, now
Machio came to the United
States, having gotten his
doctorate in Japan. And he
was phenomenal. He was a
superb mathematician, an
excellent experimentalist. He
had only rudimentary
English. But I spoke slowly
and he could understand me, and
I could understand him. Well, it
turned out that when he knew
he would be coming to the United
States in three months, he had
had no English experience at
all. And of course, he had
essentially no money. They
don't have money at his
time. And so he went
in Hawk and enrolled
in a crash course in
English language. And he
managed to get enough English
so that he could speak to me in
English in three months'
time. Now that's very
it's not so hard for a
Western speaking person to do
this. The company uses so
different that it's a tour
to force. He became much
better as time went along. So
he asked me to help him
find a place to live, which I
did. And it was very
satisfactory. It was very
low level. But I mean, after
all, he was here to do research. He
had his wife with him. He had
no children. And a few weeks
later, he came to me, he said,
did I know a doctor? He said, well,
it's probably says my wife has terrible
pains in her legs and so on.
And we'd better see a doctor.
And so I gave him the name of a
doctor that we had used for our kids.
And he came to me the next day and
he said, oh, I didn't need the doctor.
We solved the problem. The problem was
that never in Japan had this woman
been sitting in chairs. She had
always been in the Japanese
traditional position on her
knees and legs with her feet back
like this. The minute she started
to do that, all her pains
disappeared. So she could sit on
the chairs intermittently and sooner
later, the problem vanished.
Another time it came to me and
says, I need to have vitamins,
do you know where I can get vitamins?
I said, oh, yeah, you can find them in any
store. And he then told me, well,
he didn't mean that kind. I said, well,
what kind of vitamins do you mean?
He says, I want the, he says, I take
vitamins, but I inject them.
And I said, well, people don't inject
vitamins here. You can take them orally.
And on another
time he came to me and said that, well,
he spent a year, then he asked me if
he could continue another year and I said,
yes, of course you can't.
So he worked very hard and then he came
to me at that year and he said,
I've been thinking about another
apartment.
I said, and he said, I would like to have
you join me and look at it.
So it was over
on Western Avenue
where he had been living on 11th
Street in an old brick building there
with the apartment building.
And so this place was lighter and more
airy and it seemed to me like a nice
place and it was cheaper.
And he seemed very hesitant about it
and he kept looking at me.
And then sometime later he said,
you wouldn't lose face if I move
here.
Apparently on his mind because it was
cheaper, it was a downgrade and
quiet place.
And he said, you wouldn't lose face if I
moved here.
Apparently on his mind because it was
cheaper, it was a downgrade and
quality.
As a matter of fact, it was an upgrade
and quality.
But what is remarkable about this is
his having been raised in the time
maybe it still was where face is
everything.
Well, the story was incomplete
without my telling you a little
bit about his wife who was
even more remarkable.
She couldn't take English.
She knew no English and she came
here.
She came from a fairly well
off Japanese family.
Very Western whereas
Macho's family was very
traditional. His father was an
old-sea captain.
And the daughter in law was
expected to do everything in the house.
They lived.
Anyway,
she did housework
for no pay with the
stipulation that the person
for whom she worked would
speak only English to her
and try to help her understand
the English language.
And that went on for months
and she became
conversational and
English in a halting way.
Then, Macho said after his
first year he says,
now I want to buy a car,
I want a car.
So, he passed the driver's
license.
I think he failed it once,
then passed it.
Both the written and so on.
Many's wife said she wanted one.
But she couldn't read English.
She could only speak it.
And of course they give you this
manual with all the written
instruction. What the science
made everything.
She looked at the manual
and she went and took the
written exam and got
100 percent on it.
Without being able to read
any words other than stop
and slow and knowing what the
science meant.
The other thing she did
earned money,
they wanted extra money.
So, she heard herself out
when the strawberry season came
around to pick strawberries.
That was a big thing on
the big strawberry,
about twice as fast as anyone
else because she knew how to
sit on her horses.
She could go along like a rabbit
according to my understanding.
She could pick these strawberries
and they were paid
peaceways for it.
She made more money than anyone
else picking strawberries.
Well, they went back to Japan.
I visited them there on a
most remarkable experience one
time.
What happened to her?
They moved in with his
parents and she had to play
the subservient daughter.
When I was there with a friend
and revisited them we were
invited to the old people's
house.
They wore kimonos.
As we came in the door we
were professors, my friend
and I.
We had finished the travel.
That's another story.
They were on their knees with
their heads down like this
because we were professors
and we were assured
in.
But, medical, the wife of
macho did not eat dinner
with us. She served us.
She was in the kitchen all
the time.
After the parents died and
they took over the house
and they were hungry.
And as time went on her
watercolors became very
well known and then
finally she became
famous.
When she died some years
ago now, not many,
maybe five.
She was the most
talked about watercolors
in all of Japan.
There are paintings
and she made lots of money
from her painting.
Just an utterly
remarkable couple.
I feel very fortunate to have
known them.
So he's the most
remarkable postdoctoral
person I've had
from these.
I'm how they're
people of scientifically
excellent. Of course, that's
not really what I'm talking about.
But in addition to the
scientific excellence that
macho had, he had all
of the other things.
They saved money while I
were here so they could buy
an American hot water heater
and send it home
and install in these
parents' house so they
would have hot water.
And when I came to visit
them they were very worried
about the toilet facilities
because they only had the
parents on a hole in the floor
and you had the squat, you see.
So a
remarkable insight into Japanese
living.
The occasion of this,
I can tell you this visit to Japan
with macho,
Autobots Johnson, whom I mentioned
before, and I were in Japan
for a meeting.
And preliminary to that meeting
we were asked by a macho
or by some other
the principal sir.
Would you like to do something
ahead of time? And I wrote
and said, yes, we would like to
look around Japan a bit
a week ahead of time. There was a range
that macho had a car now.
It was employed by an
institute and becoming a very
well-known scientist.
We took this around in this car.
And the one thing I said to
a macho live in any American,
excuse me,
or English style
accommodations. I wanted to see
what Japan and
particularly rural Japan was like.
So as we traveled around for seven days
he had booked ahead of time
accommodations and Japanese
ends. And all the time
we were traveling on this trip,
I never saw another
Caucasian in these ends
in which we stayed.
We would come in. There would be a doorstep.
We would be met with the hostess
who would bow
and give us a kimono
you know.
And take off our shoes.
We would be ushered to our room
and some
old snack bits
after our travel would come.
And then a few minutes later
the person would come in and say,
your bath is ready.
The bath was not a
shower.
It was a huge place.
This is more or less the norm.
And there was a huge tub
was about four feet deep
and it would hold four or five people.
And it was full of
scalding water.
Then there,
away from this tub
is a tiled area
with soap along the wall.
And there is where you
get yourself. Then you got into the tub
to soak.
Then after a while you'd get out again
and repeat the process.
That's what a Japanese
that's what we were treated to.
Well, then we got out
and we were sort of
how do you want to call
totally relaxed with all of this.
We had a kimono we came back in.
This was a Japanese room.
No beds. Nothing.
You know, tatami on the floor.
A rice door.
And then there would be
a discreet knock.
And the horses would come in.
Or one of the serving girls
would come in and her kimono bowing
like this.
Set up a little table,
put the stuff on it,
and sit there.
And serve us.
Pour the sake for us.
And my Japanese, we didn't begin
in Japanese, of course.
But my Japanese friend,
who is a Japanese service,
we are,
it is a part of the process
to offer her a drink of sake.
And so we did that,
and she bowed gracefully
and drank sake very nicely.
And then at the end,
they would plurle us away
and then they would haul out the tatami
that you were going to sleep on,
bed, so to speak, the roll.
And that would be put out on the
mat on the floor.
And then we would sleep.
And every one of these rooms
was a glass partition
that opened on to a private,
very small,
not bigger than this room.
Japanese garden beautifully planted
with plants.
We went around to a number of these places,
and on one occasion
on a Saturday night,
you know, the Japanese,
they're way out on the countryside.
The men leave their family.
They go out there and they have drunken orgies.
And one of these places,
we were on the second floor
and I looked out the window in the morning.
And on this beautiful green lawn,
where a number of recumbent
forms sound asleep,
you know, where they had collapsed
after a night of drinking inside.
The Japanese don't look
at drunkenness
in the same way that we do.
I've walked through Kyoto.
And there will be a guy lying on the sidewalk.
The cops come along and very carefully
picking him up by the armpits,
dragging up to the wall
and propping him up right there
and then walk on.
Well, that's about as much as
I can tell you on that.
But that trip
is something few Americans
have ever experienced.
And when I came back to Tokyo,
Macho said, you know,
if Lisa had come with you,
we would have had none of this service.
Because she would have been expected
to perform it.
I told my wife that.
She said, it's good she didn't come along.
Yeah.
Well, as you look back
on your career in science,
what are some of the things
that you're most proud of?
Well, I think the thing
that I'm most proud
of Chris is that I've had
what I think is a very happy life
and what I've done.
My childhood was,
I won't say actually
impoverished, but we lived
through the depression
portion of which my father was out of work.
And the notion that I would have been able
to do the things
that I have been able to do
would have been
almost unthinkable.
For example, I've traveled
all over the world.
I've made much more money
than my father ever did.
And I have kids
that are successful.
And I've had wonderful colleagues.
And I've had a research career
that has kept me occupied
even to date.
I don't think I could
have
planned it any better, actually,
if I had had to
set out ahead of time.
On the other hand,
when you look back on a long life,
you see that there are certain points
where you've made decisions.
In retrospect,
you're very happy with.
But at the time,
it was almost a flip of the coin.
For example,
I very nearly married somebody
else before I met Lisa
and decided not to.
It was touch and go.
All life would have been different.
I wouldn't have had any of the same connections.
And Lisa is a gifted scientist.
I wouldn't have had anywhere near
the career I've had
were it
not for the many contributions
that she's made to it.
We sat down last night
and had a conversation
about a problem I'm having
and we came to a conclusion about it.
So, you know how it is.
And
if I'd
one of my
I don't know the way I mentioned this,
maybe I did when I got my
full bride and
cooking on fellowships to Norway.
The previous year I had
applied for a full bride fellowship.
The application received,
was received too late.
If I'd gotten it,
which I was led to believe I would have,
if it had been received in time,
I would have gone to Belgium.
I would never have had
any of this Norwegian connection.
My life would have been totally different.
Except for that week or so delay
and getting the application in.
So, when you're an old man like me,
you can think back on these
career changing decisions that you made.
So, all in all,
I would say that
I just had a very happy life.
And it's still happy, except I see
my friends falling one by one
and that's a depressing experience.
But,
comes to us all.
Well, thanks very much
if you've been to a pilot.
Yeah, well, I've enjoyed it.
Thank you.